today we're going to talk about sorting
and in particular we're going to talk
about two very well-known sorting
methods one is called selection sort the
other one is called insertion sort and
when people learn about sorting methods
they usually learn about these as being
two completely different ideas you have
a selection start on the one hand and
insertion sort on the other hand and
what I'm going to show you today is that
these are actually the same
you can regard them as being equal the
trick is that you just draw pictures of
them you don't need any coding to see
this you don't need to know any fancy
stuff in fact you don't need to know
anything about computer science at all
if you just draw a picture of selection
sort in the right way and a picture of
insertions or in the right way you see
that they're actually the same thing and
this is kind of a secret about sorting
methods that even people like me who've
been doing computer science for many
years most people are hardly anybody
actually knows this little trick we'll
start off by kind of refreshing
ourselves with pictures about what
sorting actually is so let me draw a box
what we're going to do is put some
numbers into this box doesn't matter how
many numbers everything which I'm going
to show you is completely general but
we'll do it with five so suppose we do a
five and two and three and a one and A
four these are the first five numbers
and in some kind of random order here
but the key thing is they're not sorted
they're not in ascending order and what
we'd like our sorting box to do is give
us the same numbers eight but in sorted
order so we'd like to have one two three
four and five coming out let's start to
think about how we might construct a
little program which implemented this
kind of sorting procedure here the most
basic building block which you can think
of is just a little box with four sides
what this box is going to do is on the
left hand side and on the top side
you're going to have two numbers come in
and then at the bottom the smallest
number is going to pop out and on the
right hand side the largest number is
going to pop out so you can think of
this as being like a little sorting box
for only two numbers so for example if
we put the number one in on the left
hand side and the number two in on the
top then what our little sorting box
would do is
give us the smallest one at the bottom
and it will give us the biggest one at
the right hand side so this is a sorting
box for two numbers and it doesn't
matter the order in which the two
numbers come in so if I swap this around
and if I had a two coming in here and a
one coming in here it doesn't make any
difference the smallest one is going to
pop out the bottom and the biggest one
is going to pop out the right hand side
so the game here is we've got this basic
building block and we want to kind of
plug these together and just with
pictures and see how you could build a
little sorting program the trick is that
you just build a little triangle of
these boxes so let's put a bunch of
these things together there's a little
triangle of these boxes and we're going
to just wire them together in a very
straightforward way I will just draw the
obvious little links between them and
each of these boxes just sorts two
numbers like we saw a few moments ago so
let's take our little example and just
push it through this little sorting
Network and actually see what happens so
I think the numbers we had were 5 2 3 1
& 4 so at the bottom we hope to get 1 2
3 4 5 so let's see what happens so we're
going to treat the first column first of
all and we'll see what happens so it's
really simple so you've got the 2 and
the 5 coming into the first box so the
smallest number pops out at the bottom
so that's the 2 and the biggest number
comes out the right-hand side so that's
the 5 and then we do the same with the
second box in the column so we've got a
2 coming in and a 3 coming in so the
smallest number of pops are at the
bottom and the biggest number comes out
at the right hand side and we just do
the same again then we've got a 102 so
the 1 comes out at the bottom and the 2
comes out at the right hand side and
then we've got 4 & 1 so the one pops at
the bottom and the 4 comes out at the
right hand side so what you see is that
the smallest number which in this case
has one has kind of rippled its way down
to the bottom so what's happened is this
first column has selected the smallest
number okay and it's quite easy to see
that that's the case because the top box
selects the smallest from the two
numbers it's given and then the second
box selects the smallest numbers from
the two numbers it's given and so on and
so on so kind of that the smallest
number is going to ripple its way down
to the bottom so selecting the smallest
one then we do the same with it with the
remaining columns and we won't be
surprised with what happens
we've got a three coming in and a five
coming in so the three will pop out and
the five will pop out here then we've
got a two and the three so the two is
smaller if it pops out and the three
comes out here and then we've got two
and a 4 and the 2 is the smallest and
then the four pops out the other side
you see what's happened again from the
remaining numbers 5 3 2 & 4 the second
column has selected the smallest one and
then we just complete this it's obvious
what's going to happen we get a 3 here
and a 5 here 3 4 4 5 so what you see is
that our little sorting grid has taken
five numbers in a mixed up order and
just by pushing them through one column
at a time we've ended up with the
numbers in the correct order and this is
known as selection sort because each
column just selects the smallest number
from what is left okay so nice and easy
you don't need to do anything about
computer science anything about our
rhythms anyone can understand what's
going on with selections are here but
you can actually view this picture in
another way so let me redraw the same
picture okay so just wire it up in
exactly the same way as before and we'll
push exactly the same five numbers
through so we started off with a 5 2 3 1
& 4 so what we did last time is we
treated it in terms of the columns but
actually you can do exactly the same
thing in terms of the row so we'll do
one row at a time and actually see what
happens
so we consider the first row it's the
same as before we get the 2 and the 5
coming in and the two pops out here and
5 pops out on the right-hand side
because the 2 is the smallest one so
we'll do the second row so what happens
so we've got a 2 and a 3 coming in so
the 2 is the smallest it will come out
at the bottom and the 3 is the biggest
so it comes out on the right-hand side
and then we go over to this box in the
row we've got a 3 and a 5 so the 3 comes
out at the bottom and the 5 comes out at
the right-hand side so what's actually
happened is the second row has taken the
2 and the 5 which are already in the
right order because the first box did
that for us and it's taken the 3 and
it's put the 3 into the correct place so
maybe if I use a different color here
you can see this so I've got a 2 and a 5
here and then I've got a 3 coming in on
the left-hand side and what the second
row does is it puts the 3 into the right
place so at the bottom you get two three
and five so what the second row has done
is inserted this number into the right
place and let's see what happens with an
x-ray so then we've got a 1 and a 2
coming in so the 1 comes out at the
bottom because it's the smallest and
then the 2 comes out here we've got a 2
and a 3 so we get the 2 and the 3 and
then we've got a 3 and a 5 and the 3 is
this more so it comes out here what you
see is exactly the same thing has
happened again we had a 1 here and then
we had 2 3 & 5 which is already being
sorted by the grid above us and then
this row here is just going to put the 1
into the right place what's popped out
at the bottom of this grid is 1 2 3 & 5
so we just complete the picture
we'll get the expected result so we've
got a 1 and a 4 so the 1 is the smallest
so it pops at the bottom and the 4 goes
around here then we've got 2 & a 4 so
the two pops out and the 4 and the 3 and
the 4 so 3 is smallest and then we get
the 4 and the 5 this sorting method when
you think about the rows rather than the
columns is called insertion sort and
it's called insertion sort because each
of these rows just inserts a number into
the correct position in a sorted
sequence so for example if we look at
the bottom row here the input on the top
is a sorted sequence 1 2 3 and 5 those
are in the right order and all the
bottom row is doing is putting this 4
into the correct position so that we get
1 2 3 4 & 5 previously we had exactly
the same picture and we said that
selection sort if you view it in terms
of the columns and if you take the same
picture now and view it in terms of the
rows this way around then we get
insertion sort so for me this is a bit
of magic I've been doing computer
science for a long long time I was
thinking about how to teach sorting
algorithms to my students of years ago
and they came up with this pictorial
idea and I didn't realize until then
that insertion sort and selection sort
are exactly the same thing but you only
see this if you look at it in the right
way using the pictures basically it so
comes all the other perspective right
yes exactly it's it's this if you look
at stuff in the right way then you can
see things that you couldn't see before
so if you write programs to do insertion
sort our selections are the kind of
structure here which is the same
as being is being kind of hidden from
you but if you just draw some simple
pictures and forget all your fancy
computing then you end up with an
observation which is quite interesting
have you come across anything else that
is kind of a similar view have you gone
through other sort of algorithms and
thought thoughts about them this way
yeah so a colleague of mine from Oxford
a few years ago we I was showing him
this to him and he said oh we can write
a paper about this so we tried to look
at like quicksort and mergesort
and see if they were at the same kind of
duality but it didn't quite work out at
the time and we kind of gave up writing
the paper about it but I think this is
just a simple observation in its own
right here it's very difficult for a
firewall or something to notice this
because these are valid HTTP requests
they're just super slow right and you
know maybe I've just got really bad
internet connection maybe